[Musik]
so das war's ich kann nicht mehr lernen
was du bist jetzt nicht weiß wirst du in
den nächsten zwei stunden auch nicht
mehr hinbekommen würde ich lieber noch
ein bisschen aus dassow rechts
überraschung es ist dass das hier ist
die wahlbenachrichtigung für die
landtagswahl im nächsten monat
ich kann mich nie entscheiden liberal
sozial naja also hauptsache nicht
konservativ das kann man so auch nicht
sagen wen oder was spielt man in
deutschland es ist ein bisschen
kompliziert
also im nächsten monat wählen wir den
landtag für das bundesland in dem wir
wohnen dann gibt es noch kommunalwahl
bundestagswahl und europawahl sebastian
versteht es scheinbar auch nicht so ganz
also ich verstehe es gut genug um keinen
quatsch zu wählen wir leben in einer
demokratie
viele meinungen sind erlaubt und wählt
man eine person oder eine partei es ist
so mit der erststimme wählt man den
kandidaten des jeweiligen wahlkreises
mit der zweitstimme die partei wenn eine
partei oder bzw wende von einer partei
mehrere kandidaten gewählt wurden als
diese zahl hat dann gibt es
überhangmandate
aber so genau weiß ich das auch nicht
[Musik]